the key thing is focus how do you
understand
where are the opportunities that you can
actually win
what are the opportunities that you
can't win and how to walk away from the
ones that you can't win
[Music]
thank you so much for joining me on 20
minute leaders thanks michael
where are you calling from it looks like
meteor agrees but i think i'm wrong
uh actually the picture behind me is uh
is from telluride colorado but i'm in
court of madera so eight miles north of
the golden gate bridge right now
oh you're eight miles of the goal of the
golden gate wonderful
the picture is a picture i took over
july 4th last weekend
last year last year wonderful actually i
believe
this episode is going to air sometime
later on so maybe it will be last
weekend
july 4th we'll see the extensive
experience
in the tech sector you know from 8200
to and to the your mba at nyu
uh leading the entrepreneurship cert
segment there going on to varant vp at
nice
your own startup which you've already
co-founded before and now you're uh
now you're a part of neural legion
another startup
take me through your journey just a
little bit give me a brief of who who is
gadi
all right happy uh happy to start there
maybe i'll even start a bit earlier
wonderful for that though originally
from israel but i got to grow up in a
bunch of different countries
okay which always makes it makes it fun
um that instilled the level of travel in
me i've
been to 110 countries
you've been to 110 countries okay
throw everything else out the window or
i don't i just want to talk about that
what does that mean i want to talk
travel it's funny because i was talking
to
one of our prospects yesterday and he
said yeah i'd like to go to new zealand
and i started
on the call with a whole plan for him
i'm okay this is what you need to do you
need to go there this is how you do it
that's how you travel
that's how i usually end up
conversations i'm the travel agent for
anybody who knows me so
gotti this is incredible how do you get
to 110 countries
uh well a lot of it is is you know
growing up in europe as a kid my parents
used to throw us in the back of the car
and just drive around so i'd been to
about 30 countries by the age of 10. and
then you you just fall in love with it
and you find
jobs over time that let you travel and
go see a lot of other places so
in the period between we're getting a
bit off topic but i think that's okay
in a period between 2001
and 2012 i traveled 2.2 million miles
and traveled and visited about 70
different countries so
most of them for work but i got to
extend that and have some fun
wow okay that's uh that's just
incredible
going back to entrepreneurship but we're
gonna continue so
we're continuing this right after the
recording okay
excellent so um started there came back
to israel after a few years in europe
um 8200 customary
um customary plan for anybody in in
cyber i then got my undergrad at tel
aviv university
um and went into the joyous world of
of high tech um founded my first startup
in
in 99 um after my first company
that's a very interesting that's a very
interesting time to start a company
it was a very actually it was a great
time to start a company unfortunately
two years later it was less of a great
uh time to raise a series a which is
what we were in the midst of
um but uh things actually went pretty
well and
we ended up selling uh the company's
strange story we actually split it in
two
and uh nice acquired part of it and
baron declared another part
and i went to one place and my partner
and co underwent to the other place
wow um and
uh that's that's how i joined parent i
was with them on the product side for
about a year and a half in
in israel and then they moved me to the
u.s
this was part of the expansion of the
company and very very was a fun run i
was there for six years we went from
150 people to 200 2500 people
we went public uh we we went from about
15 million dollars in sales to 400
million dollars in sales
what was your role in the company as you
were watching this incredi
incredible journey was running product
of the product management organization
um and then when i moved here um i
started a pre-sales group then a
business consulting group and did
customer success
uh did some direct sales so i got to see
everything from the front lines and then
it was
very interesting to work on some very
large opportunities so selling to
first of all the irs here in the us then
a t
t-mobile sprint some of the large banks
working on deals anywhere from 10
million to 40 million dollars
this is pre-sas so that was uh that was
an exciting period and i learned a lot
in parallel what you brought up earlier
is i got my mba at nyu
right that was the that was my weekend's
job um
and i anna ran the entrepreneurship club
for the entrepreneurial exchange even
though i was a part-time student i i
really wanted to get involved found an
apartment a block and a half away from
stern
and that enabled me to uh to really
get involved there but alas after six
years
in the variant the company um it got a
bit too big after a big acquisition we
did and i decided it was time to move on
and
joined a company called merced systems
here on the west coast
okay i moved um at the end of 2007 to
san francisco uh joined merced pretty
early on we were with
25 people something like that at the
time
um pretty small and um
when five years later we were acquired
by
nice the the great thing about merced is
that uh we only raised one round of
funding we only raised two and a half
million dollars and we were profitable
from year two oh my god
wait so that was that was the second
company you're involved with that nice
was involved in the acquisition
right exactly wow interesting
coincidence
uh uh it's all in the same space all in
the same space
so yes and no interesting
gadi i want to give time to talk about
cyber security because this is also a
sweet spot for me
after my own five years in 8200 neuro
legion
you know we're a part of i'm a part of j
ventures
so so proud to be to be a part of the
fund
that helped uh invest in new religion
give me the give me the pitch what is
nora legion why is
app security so prevalent and so
important in 2020
yeah absolutely i think the the key
thing that we do or the key couple of
things that we do that are very
different and very
innovative in the market is we took the
approach
from the beginning from the time the
inside of the company was created
that we want to provide a tool for a
developer
we do not want to go into the security
organization and tell them here's a
cya tool that you can go ahead and
deploy and say that it will work and you
get the reports that you need no we
wanted
to provide a tool to companies that they
can
integrate very early on into their
development processes
and make sure that developers are using
it but that's the reason we called it
from build to compliance
right it can be deployed on every build
but you can build on that and go from
that to say
okay i've secured the build now i've
secured the application now i've secured
the product
and now i get my compliance reports and
you do that
all in one holistic way across all of
your environment so you're not just
testing your applications but you're
testing your apis which is critical
today more and more organizations are
using that
you're using you're testing your mobile
applications and
also any modern technology that you're
using like single page applications or
authentic
authenticated sites or if you're in a
microservices environment
we can support all that because we are
inherently built in the cloud and we're
not a legacy solution
talk to me a little bit how do you grow
a company like this fine so you have
great
you have great talent to understand the
space you write a great solution
now what so you have yeah you have a
million sas products but you're knocking
on the doors you're offering
another you know security another layer
how do you sell this thing
i think the critical thing is one you
need to understand how you're different
and where you're different
and this actually ties into your other
question of how do you grow a slow
growing company though that's not the
case here
but the key thing is focus how do you
understand
where are the opportunities that you can
actually win
what are the opportunities that you
can't win and how to walk away from the
ones that you can't win
there's a lot of people that waste a ton
of time on places that ultimately will
just waste their time and they're not
able to win
but one of the things and that's a
critical thing that i implemented the
minute i joined here and many other
companies
is we do not join a meeting and do a
demo as the first meeting right all
these companies join a meeting and
immediately start
talking at the customer absolutely not
our first meeting is a discovery meeting
you are going to talk to us
in the first meeting and we'll spend 15
20 minutes understanding
what your actual challenges are and once
we know what they are
then we'll come back we'll prepare and
we'll present back to you
if we think that we can't help you we
will tell you that on the first call so
we don't waste your time or our time
because that's
that's our most sacred resource it's in
time of course
and is this is this diverging from the
common way that
that you know any sas company operates
today
i think that modern sales organizations
know this and they do that
but go to any website that you have
right and click it what is the call to
action that they have
requested request a demo
no i don't believe in that you can't you
can request to them or you're not going
to get one immediately right it's how
you capture people and how you get them
so i think that modern sales
organizations absolutely understand this
i did not invent the concept of
ask questions first and learn and then
adapt
but it's something that a lot of people
get wrong um
and and that's how you get started then
you actually need to have a superior
product you need to be able to go up in
pocs
and beat anybody in the competition i'm
happy to say that we've done
you know 20 25 pocs in the last four
months and we've never lost
we've beat each and every one of them
that's what we invested
that's why we're so proud yeah well you
invested before these four months but
yes
hopefully hopefully the follow-up will
happen soon
we'll
isn't this the role of the investors
though to always then say yeah i knew
this before and
and that's how we're in all right got it
you know one of the things that that
that you that we talked about right
before starting is this notion of you
know
taking a large company or a large
organization and
that is slowly growing and understanding
how can we
you know pivot to scale so that we can
go much quicker than we can
you had experience doubling sometimes
the sales and like
periods of 18 months which is incredible
talk to me a little bit about this
notion
what makes a company grow slow and what
makes the company grow fast
yeah i i think it's it's touching on
somebody who already talked about
something we already talked about
the key thing is what are the levers
that you can pull
yeah what do you need to stop doing the
first thing that you need to understand
is what do i need to stop doing i love
it okay what am i doing that's just
wasting time okay and i should not be
doing because even if i do it
it won't help us grow right
and that's a critical critical thing
once you understand
what you need to stop doing you need to
understand
what are the levers that you can pull
and really there are a few levers in the
area of sales
that you can pull one is you can
increase your
average contract value right that's a
very big one they need to understand how
do you do that you need to change your
pricing model do you need
to change your go to market do you need
to change the customers you're selling
to
do you need to um update what
uh how you package the product etc right
that's one critical thing
the next thing is can you change your
sales cycle if there's something you're
doing in your sales cycle that is
preventing you from going faster
and you have the ability to now shorten
that sales cycle and have more impact
right the third one is how are you
actually going to market right are you
going
direct and are you having meetings in
person
this this whole covid thing that
happened right now is really teaching us
that
yes you can do enterprise sales over
zoom
because somehow we've all gotten
comfortable doing that that's not
something that organizations
uh were perceiving or uh admitting that
can be done earlier but maybe that could
change but you know i was just having
i was having coffee with a good friend
from the from the stanford business
school and one of the things he was
telling me is you know michael one of
the things that is happening
a lot of a lot of really great sales
people it's not just about the demo and
about city and about
you know talking it's about the whole
experience it's coming in maybe going
for a nice lunch getting to know the
other person critical
well you can't do that anymore now i'm
si i can be sitting in my underwear
right now we don't know like this is
a whole different conversation yeah i
think i'm not in my underwear
just not even
but um i think the the it is interesting
right because i have done this huge
enterprise sales where
in the end people buy from people right
and that is a very important component
there are um circumstances right now
that have changed that
do i think that ultimately once this
whole proven thing is over
we will not revert a bit towards
yes still establishing relationships and
still having a drink together for large
enterprise deals and still forming
relationships absolutely not that is
going to come back and
quite frankly it's one of the the parts
of the job that i like so it would be
sad
uh being a traveler and love meeting
people etc i love that part
it would be sad if that went away i
don't believe it will
but definitely you're learning what
kinds of opportunities do not require
that
amazing and how to differentiate between
the two
why come back to early stage startups
um i'd say there are well i i was i
never left really apart from variant
which was a more mature company i i
always go back and and
but you're also a vp at nice
okay so i was there post acquisition and
and helping the transition etc so
i i constantly come back to early stage
startups at some point i
i will stop doing that because
it is very very hard work but i would
say for me it's three things one is
it's really having the ability to make
an impact
and at earlier stages every step that
you do has
much more significant impact right um
and and that's one thing i love uh two
in the case of neurolegion
it was really going back to the origins
i i started in cyber security i thought
it was time to go back to it
um i understand this market and i really
saw an opportunity it can provide value
and three um there were there were quite
frankly threats on my life sean marcio
has been my best friend for 40 years
and and he told me that it was time for
me to come back and start working
together and
how many opportunities do you get to
work with your best friend that's
incredible that that's just incredible
you know talk to me a little bit about
this cyber security space
where are we headed what what do what
are some of the greatest challenges
in the space as a whole not not just
norwegian but it's a
space as a whole that you're seeing now
as you're
talking to so many different companies
who are in need of cyber solutions
i think i think the market is really
shifting and it shifted much more
significantly over the last
three months than people expected but
this
just pushed a lot of trends that had
already started
the number of threats is going up
continuously right it never stopped and
organizations are facing
new and and um more dangerous threats
all the time now especially with
everybody working from home the whole
would you believe three months ago if i
told you that meat can is going to
disappear and there are new solutions
that will replace vpn we've been playing
around with vpn for so many i don't know
25 years now
right so that's going away um
there's a huge change and i think one of
the biggest trends that we're seeing is
that really
the world of software is eating
everything right man
mark andreessen yeah software's eating
the world and now
exactly right and and now that's coming
to security as well you can't
have two different organizations now
where the security organization that
enforces stuff in the development
organization no
that's gone that's it all right they are
one organization now and if you can't
have security from the ground up you're
going to have
a problem and we're seeing that in every
single page of
every single part of cyber security um
and and
really there's a great thing in english
which everybody knows which is an
ounce of prevention is worth a pound of
cure and integrating all these solutions
into the development process is that odd
ounce of prevention it will save
organizations a lot of money
and make them a lot more secure by the
time and that's that's exactly what
we're trying to help drive
but it's not enough for any young
company to just come in and say yeah we
have a sas
we have we have software and norwegian
and extend
and a few others come along and
integrate let's makes let's be secure
do you need a are do companies as early
as you know
a poc or or an mvp do they already need
a
somebody who's knowledgeable with cyber
security space within the company or
do do you think this can be outsourced
and just plug in
installations from other companies so i
think i think there are
three options that organizations can
look at because the threat profile is
different from different kinds of
organizations right if you're a large
and mature organization and
your visa or your city bank or your
government
right better how they do know that there
are a lot of people that are excited to
attack you yeah
right so you better have this in place
and you have
better have real expert in place that
are
dynamic and thinking on their feet and
know what they're doing
if you're a mid-sized organization
that's developing
solutions etc or a very early stage
company
absolutely adapt these practices that
are the right practices from the
beginning
integrate them into your processes but
you can use
third-party tools for this right the
third approach which
which we're definitely seeing is there
are outsourced companies that help you
with this
and maybe it's taking a hybrid approach
of the first uh
of the the latter two in order to really
get secure as you grow
i love it gadi right before we leave and
thank you again for the time and
inspiration
and and i'm excited to continue learning
as much as i can from you along the way
i need three words from you that best
describe you and you know
a little bit about what are you truly
passionate about
is this yeah it's always a question when
you get asked this
is that how others would describe me or
how i would describe i'm gonna
i'm gonna let you choose which one i'll
go with
and also when i say others is it my
coworker my wife
who's the one that uh the dogs in its
tree dispenser that's as far as there
you go
um i would say um unconventional
i don't necessarily do things in the
standard way that they
would be done otherwise um
tenacious okay i like that
and uh the one that that i've heard of
time and time again that i like is uh
the gst get done
i love it yes talk is cheap
wonderful gotti today thank you very
very much
and uh and best of luck with everything
hockey